one of the most common requests that I
receive on the channel is to cover more
love stories within mythology and with
stabian Valentine's Day it seems like a
perfect time to discuss eros the Greek
god of love now the exact origins and
where eros came from do slightly vary in
some accounts eros is a primordial being
a child of chaos he was also responsible
for blessing the union between Gaia and
Uranus who then created the universe as
we know it in Greek mythology
he was almost seen as a facilitator
encouraging the unions between other
primordial deities the ancient
tragedians saw eros is both positive and
negative as the unions he created would
often lead to virtue as well as misery
in these older depictions he's often
seen as a plump overweight child
carrying a bow you might be somewhat
familiar with his Roman counterpart
Cupid anyone who was hit by the arrows
he would fire would fall instantly in
love but the question of whether he
chose his targets carefully or just
fired at random knowing that they would
fall in love regardless is one that I'll
leave you to consider in the later
accounts and the depictions that
followed eros was considered to be the
son of Aphrodite the goddess of love and
beauty there are some conflicting
beliefs as to who exactly his father was
who some believe in it could have been
Hermes another Zeus but it's widely
regarded that the God of War Ares was
his true father the physical appearance
of Aris also shifted in these depictions
much like his mother and his father he
was considered extremely beautiful
different vastly from images of a plump
child but he was still regarded as a
constant source of trouble for both gods
and mortals eros is often described as
the God of love but it's very important
for us to note that there are many
different types of love eros himself was
a very passionate God and that is
represented by the type of love he had
control over he could make anyone fall
in love instantly whether those
individuals remained in love was another
story he was a God who lived very much
in the present it's because of this we
can almost see him as the God of passion
but with passion comes sexual activity
and that is why he was also associated
with fertility
if we take a look at his brother and
tariffs he was also considered a God of
love but in a very different way and
terrorist was considered the god of a
quieted love essentially love that had
been returned or rejected and thus he
was often associated with the concept of
mutual love he was also seen as quite a
vengeful God taking actions against
those who rejected the love of others
the two brothers are quite often seen as
opposites and there are depictions of
them on an opposite end of a scale to
show their differences but despite their
different views on love the two brothers
physical appearance was quite similar
and even to this day statues of aunt
eros are quite often mistaken for arrows
the two brothers are often depicted as
long-haired males with wings carrying a
bow but depictions of aunt arrows
slightly differ at times he can be seen
carrying a golden club and unlike his
brother his wings are more plumed
similar to that of a butterfly Eris did
have a number of followers or minor
deities that he was associated with
pothos and amuro's were amongst the ones
are most commonly seen by his side and
they were thought to represent longing
and desire there were quite a few winged
gods who were associated with love and
desire they were referred to as the gyro
tease and their exact number does tend
to vary but besides the ones we've just
mentioned they seemed to have no
distinct mythology which has led many to
believe that they were created to be
used in poetic stories and not much more
perhaps one of the most well-known love
stories in all of Greek mythology is
that of Eros and Psyche a tale of love
heartbreak and determination there was
once a king who had three daughters of
great beauty but his youngest daughter
psyche possessed the beauty that had
never been seen before many considered
her appearance to be perfection when
people laid their eyes upon her they
would often say that not even Aphrodite
could compete with such beauty with more
and more people paying attention to
psyches beauty they began to forget the
goddess her temples were abandoned and
the sculptors who once crafted
marvellous statues of her now did
sophist psyche Aphrodite began to fade
from existence
but the goddess would not sit idly and
do nothing as she watched the mortal
girl replace her she commanded her son
eros to aid her use your power make this
little shameless girl fall in love with
the vilest and most despicable creature
that has ever walked the earth she
commanded her son to shoot psyche with
one of his arrows but when he first laid
his eyes upon her he was instantly
captivated almost as if his heart had
been pierced by one of his own arrows
arrows was face of a situation that
would end poorly regardless of his
choice if he did what his mother asked
him then he would potentially lose the
love of his life but if he disobeyed his
mother he would have to face the
consequences he eventually decided that
he would ignore his mother's commands
and say nothing of what had happened
despite being the most beautiful woman
on earth psyche was extremely lonely she
was unable to make a meaningful
connection with anyone thousands of men
or an oral psyche but they were happy
just admiring and worshipping her no man
dare to approach or court her almost as
if she was too sacred she watched as her
sisters had lavished weddings with Kings
wishing that one day that would be her
her father was so desperate to find out
what he could do to help his daughter
that he visited the Oracle of Delphi
where he asked Apollo what he could do
to find his or her husband Apollo told
the king that he should take his
daughter to the summit of a mountain
where in a black dress and there once
alone she would be given a husband a
terrifying winged serpent that even the
gods feared her family was devastated by
the news but Saiki began her ascent to
the top of the mountain not knowing what
evil awaited her psyche waited on the
cliff top for hours in the cold
shivering and crying until she felt a
wind of Zephyr and all of a sudden she
rose into the air the Zephyr eased her
pain and placed her to sleep when she
woke she was in a soft meadow of freshly
cut flowers in front of a castle so
magical that it had to belong to a God
when she approached the castle it
appeared to be uninhabited but she heard
a faint voice the house is for you come
in and do not be afraid take a bath and
then we were honor your arrival after
doing so Saiki sat patiently waiting for
her husband to appear she could feel his
presence was close and eventually he
whispered into her ear she could tell by
his voice that he was no monster but
rather the husband she had always wished
for she would spend most of the day
bored waiting for her husband to arrive
in the evening but when he did he
brought with him great joy she was still
unable to physically see her husband
which did bring her a degree of sadness
so she asked him for one favor to allow
her to see her family as it would
comfort her
and first her husband said no but as
Saiki sadness grew he changed his mind
I will allow your sisters to visit the
castle but heed my warning if you allow
them to influence you our relationship
will be destroyed and they will be
suffering the following day psyche
sisters arrived and there were tears of
joy as they were so pleased to finally
see each other again her sisters were
taken back by all the treasures found in
a castle
they had a host of questions for psyche
your husband must be a king or even
better a God psyche told them that he
was a young hunter but the two sisters
disregarded her answer as a hunter could
not be so rich the sisters began to be
consumed by jealousy they knew their
happiness paled in comparison to psyches
and thus they hatched a plan to hurt
their sister before the sisters left
they began to taunt psyche your husband
must be the evil snake the Oracle
prophesized and that is why you never
see him we pity you sister how could you
live with such a horrid creature Saki
tried her best to ignore what her sister
said but they had planted the seed of
doubt and she could not get the thoughts
out of her head why else would he never
visit me during the day what is he
hiding from me tonight when he's asleep
I would light a candle to see him if he
appears as a snake then I will kill him
if I am wrong I would douse my flame and
sleep happy later that night when her
husband fell asleep she lit her candle
and slowly began to approach him the
light did not reveal a monster but the
most handsome man she had ever seen
psyche was ashamed of the lack of trust
she had shown in her husband and when
she went to douse her flame the hot wax
fell onto her husband waken him he
looked into her eyes he wasn't angry but
rather heartbroken he left their bedroom
and before he flew into the dark sky she
heard him whisper one last time love
cannot live without trust the god of
love was my husband and I did not trust
him she said in despair Saiki wept for
days on end until she eventually decided
that
would do anything to win back the love
of her husband she visited Aphrodite's
temple and prayed to the goddess asking
her to persuade her son to take her back
Aphrodite will still overcome with
jealousy and wanted her revenge
she told psyche in order to make sure
that she was an appropriate wife for her
son she would have to prove herself by
completing a series of tasks only then
would the goddess help her for the first
task
Aphrodite showed psyche thousands of
different seeds and told her if you
cannot separate these you will never see
my son again but how could she sought
all of these seeds it was impossible it
would take forever she began to weep
uncontrollably but her cries were heard
by a nearby passing colony of ants they
took pity upon the crying girl and they
began to help psyche sort the seeds and
after a short period every single seed
was sorted into the cordon pile
Aphrodite had hoped that the hard work
and labor would have affected psyches
beauty but it did not for the next task
Aphrodite told Saiki that she would have
to make a fleece from the golden sheep
that lay across the river while Saiki
swam across the river a spirit appeared
to her warning her of how dangerous the
golden sheep were the spirit told her to
avoid being killed by the Sheep she
should collect the fur from the nearby
bushes listening to the advice she had
been given psyche collected enough to
make a golden fleece and in this task
she was successful
the next task that Aphrodite set was
just as dangerous as the last she asked
psyche to climb a waterfall that led to
the River Styx and fill a bottle she had
been given one psyche reached the
waterfall she realized that her
surrounding rocks were way too steep and
slippery to climb the task also seemed
impossible but once again to her
surprise an eagle had flown over the
river taken the bottle from her hand and
filling it with the black water from the
river Styx Aphrodite could not hide her
bitterness someone helped you otherwise
you would not have been able to perform
this task by yourself I will give you
one last chance to prove that you are as
determined as you claim to be for her
last task she was given a box to take to
the underworld which she would have to
ask Persephone to place some of her
beauty inside of it Saiki began her
perilous journey to the underworld and
once arriving she asked Persephone to
drop some of her beauty into the box
Persephone was more than happy to serve
Aphrodite and so she did so when Saiki
returned to earth she was more curious
than ever about the box
if it contained pure beauty then she
should open the box to look even more
radiant for her husband but when she did
the box did not contain beauty but only
sleep she had been tricked by Aphrodite
and psyche fell into a deep slumber the
rest of the gods watched on and decided
that they would take action against
Aphrodite's wrongdoing Hermes was sent
to deliver a message to eros informing
him of his wife's misfortunes Eris was
overcome by what he heard and the wound
of betrayal finally began to heal he
finally left his room in search for
psyche when he found her he was able to
wake her from her slumber and the two
were able to reconcile
the men back on earth had forgotten all
about psyche and once again began
worshipping Aphrodite as the true
goddess of beauty the story of Eros and
Psyche touches on many issues including
trust jealousy revenge and lust in the
end we see the determination of psyche
and what many consider to be the power
of true love overcome all obstacles for
those of you wondering why eros didn't
show himself to psyche from the very
beginning he believed that true love
between a God and a human was impossible
and that if he showed himself the psyche
he would lose her the story shows us
that true love is by no means easy it
requires sacrifice trust and
determination even if you are the God of
love himself I hope you guys enjoyed
today's Valentine's themed video if you
did then let me know what you thought in
the comments below but as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained
you